intel abiad le drapeau kurde a cédé sa
place au drapeau de l'armée syrienne
libre
jadis symbole de la rébellion contre
bachar al assad
le drapeau est aujourd'hui synonyme
d'une victoire de la turquie pour qui la
milice syrienne se bat mes frères ou
vous soyez dans le monde
vous devriez rentrer un thé labyad dix
commandants la ville est saine et sauve
ces combattants supplétifs de la turquie
ne perd pas de temps pour faire régner
leur loi dans la ville frontalière
nous ne voulons que la sécurité on ne
demande plus rien d'autre que la
sécurité dit cet homme revenu après
avoir dormi dans les buissons pour
échapper aux combats qui ont précédé il
aura fallu moins d'une semaine pour que
les kurdes soit défait les milices pro
turc contrôle aujourd'hui tu es labyad
et une quarantaine de villages de la
zone frontalière jusqu'à l'ouest grâce à
green une ville qui jusqu'ici le riche à
ses victoires turcs sont aussi
paradoxalement un gain énorme pour
bachar al assad
sans avoir tiré un seul coup sacrifier
un seul soldat l'armée syrienne est de
retour à mendy gecko banner à la
frontière turque et s'apprête à entrer
dans kamichli la capitale et hassaké sur
l'arrière front n'avait d'autre choix
que de sacrifier leur autonomie distille
dès lundi matin les forces de damas se
sont déployés à telgte amer pour marcher
vers la frontière
mais loin de reculer l'armée turque a
continué de masse et ses soldats près de
la frontière entre autres ici dans la
ville de hat chacal est où des dizaines
de civils ont été tués par les tirs des
kurdes depuis près d'une semaine de
remous sociaux twitter
peu importe les menaces et les pressions
nous sommes déterminés à poursuivre
notre opération jusqu'au bout je le dis
clairement nous allons terminer ce que
nous avons commencé dit le président
ordonne à ne plus livrer des gens
l'union européenne a de nouveau condamné
l'opération turque sans imposer un
embargo unanimes sur les ventes d'armes
à la turquie les pays membres
s'entendent pour ne plus en vendre à
ankara le président erdogan a vivement
dénoncé cette décision affirmant que de
refuser de vendre des armes à la turquie
favorise le terrorisme
mais qui se préoccupe encore du
terrorisme dans ce jeu géopolitique
d'alliance qui se nouent et se dénouent
sans cesse les kurdes en maintes fois
prévenu le chaos et l'instabilité vont
permettre aux cellules dormantes de
lehideux s'activer au prisonnier qui
rêvent d'évasion ou de libération de
filet pour reprendre du service et
poursuivre leur jihad
un scénario catastrophe qui semble se
concrétiser cinq prisonniers se serait
évadé à qamichli vendredi une émeute ce
dimanche aurait permis à d'autres
prisonniers de prendre le large
les cures de blâmer bombardement de la
turquie qui l accusent les milices
kurdes de vider les prisons à dessein et
pendant ce temps en pliant bagages les
américains laisserait derrière une
cinquantaine de prisonniers de grande
valeur pour les états unis
ici marie-eve bédard radio-canada au
kurdistan irakien